Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kelly Holderman, staff clinician at the Connors Clinic.
Today, we're going to be discussing the pulsing method. And this method in short is an
approach to figuring out how much of a supplement you need, and at what point you should increase
the dose, decrease it, or cut the supplement out altogether. And I will say that if you're
listening to this video, you probably have had kinesiology where we have figured out
exactly what you need for your cancer, for Lyme disease, or other ailments. And so this
isn't really talking about the supplementation in terms of what we've tested and what we've
put you on. So this is more of a method for let's say that you heard that glutathione is really
good. And you want to start taking glutathione, or your neighbor said that they got really
good results from NADH, and you want to give that a try. So this is kind of above and beyond,
because a lot of people, when they come in, they have a suitcase full of supplements, and they're
not quite sure what is harming them, or what is helping them. And we, of course, will help you
sort through all of those. So this is just a tool, if you're going to bring in something new,
and of course you can always make an appointment with us, and we can guide you through it. But I
really think that the pulsing method is something that when you learn about it, it can be really
cool, because it can be really even used for food. So let's say you want to start eating more
sulfur foods, because you heard that they can help increase glutathione production. And you can use
this method to sort out what your body needs, and how much of a substance it needs. So let's talk
about some tips. So on every bottle of pills that we carry, and most places carry even
target been Walgreens, and all over, they have suggested uses, where it says something to
extent of, take this pill three times a day with meals. And so I just want to remind everybody
that suggested use is just a suggestion. And that is based on averages, and most people maybe fit
underneath that, those recommendations, but really some people need much, much, much less, where
taking that much of the suggested use can actually get them into trouble. So just take that for
what it's worth. That if you'll say your neighbor recommends that you start on some energy drink or
pill or something that gave them really a lot more energy for the day, that they may have taken
three a day, and you may have the benefit with taking a fourth of one or a very much lower dose
or a higher dose. So just keep that in mind. And so that's what we're going to go through and how to
teach you to do that. I will say that starting one thing at a time is really important as well,
because we want to sort out what could be making you feel poorly, and what could be making you feel
better. So if you decide that you want to start on three different supplements other than what we
what we recommended, then try to try to space them out at least so you have an idea. So let's say you
decide that you need to take some, you feel like I just need some B12. I feel like maybe you know I
want some extra energy. So I'm going to try this B12 and you start to take it and you may find that
you're getting a benefit from it. So taking more of it is not necessarily what you want to do. You
want to make sure that your body's utilizing it. You're not overdosing yourself. So again, taking
one thing at a time, then you can kind of sort out when your body's had too much of something and when
your body is in that that Goldilocks area. And we're going to talk about that. And then thirdly is
to understand what the supplement is designed to do. So let's say for instance, you heard that NADH
is really, really good and you decide to take it. Well, let's figure out what is it supposed to do.
So NADH is really an energy molecule in the electron transport chain. So in essence, if you take it,
you should get some positive effect where there would be decreasing fatigue, better brain function,
something. So if you're taking it and you have no idea what it's supposed to do, that's not that's
not very good. So we want to make sure that we're looking at a supplement, we're educating ourselves
on why are we taking this and what kind of effects can I feel for it. And then you'll have a better idea
when you're trying to sort out if the supplement is making you feel better or worse or that you haven't
reached that Goldilocks area, then you'll have an idea of what you're looking for. So Goldilocks and
the Three Bears. So I have a two-year-old, he's going to be two this month, and he loves this story. And
as I was thinking about the pulsing method, I was thinking that's exactly what we're trying to
accomplish here. We're trying to get the supplementation that we're choosing in that area where it's
doing the best for our body, where it's not too little, it's not too much, it's just right.
And so I like the analogy here, the Goldilocks area being under the bell curve. So under the bell
curve is the area of that substance. Let's just say, let's say B12. So you're you're just right,
your body's really thriving, you're doing really well. So let's just say that when you start taking
the B12, for instance, you're over here on the deficient end, you're kind of sluggish, you're going to
tired, and you start taking it. So we're going to start taking it along the way. Day three or week three,
or what, you know, it's different for every supplement. You get into the Goldilocks area,
and you start to get some benefit from that supplement. Okay, so that here is one of the main points
of this whole entire presentation is that the moment that you feel great is the moment you should stop
or reduce supplemental, supplementing that nutrient. So you're taking your B12, you're deficient,
you don't notice anything, you don't notice anything, you keep on taking it, and let's say like four
days later, you're like, wow, I'm starting to feel really good. You could just just hold up and
know that you need to change the dose. I would say either cut back to a fourth of it or a half of it,
or just stop it for a day or two, and just see how you can ride that good feeling out, just see how
long that's going to last, because if you keep taking it, okay, so I'm feeling really good. I'm in
this Goldilocks area, I keep taking it, keep taking it, guess what happens? You end up over here
on the right, and you end up having too much of that particular substance. We see this all the time,
because the paradigm of take this pill the rest of your day, days, you know, take one every morning,
the rest of your life is really not how your body works at all. I mean, there's some things where
your body doesn't need a steady concentration of something, but really, when you get prescribed
something or someone suggests it, if you keep taking, taking, taking, taking, taking it, eventually,
you might end up in that toxic area, and that's where when people come in with all kinds of
supplementation, we make sure that they're not overdoing it, that they're not too toxic, which is
more over the case than being deficient in things. And we sort that out for you. If you, again,
if you have any questions about that, definitely post it on the Facebook page here, and we can kind of
talk about that, but really, when you leave Connor's clinic, you should have your supplementation based
on, you know, we're dosing you in your Goldilocks area, which is really cool. So we give you an idea
of where your body is supposed to be, and then you can kind of play with it a little bit. Let's say,
you know, you got put on some glutathione, or you decided to take some at home, and maybe your body
is a little deficient. You have some genetic snips in there that Dr. Connors talks about, where your
body doesn't make it very well. So for instance, I don't make glutathione very well. So I kind of hang out
down in the deficient area. So I'll start taking it for a couple days, just a couple drops, because
we're going to talk about different forms of supplementation and how some can be a lot stronger,
per se than others. So I'll start taking my liposomal glutathione. And pretty soon, I know I've
had, I've increased energy. I know that something's kicking in, and I'll be in my Goldilocks area. So I
will stop. I will literally stop taking it, and I will see how long I can ride that good feeling out.
Now let's say I kept taking it, and I'm going to end up over here, and I'm not going to feel very well. So
that pulsing method staying within this area is different for each person, but this is a really
powerful tool where you can learn what your body needs, and how much your body needs of that.
So let's talk about the different bell curves, because see how this one was nice and fat and wide.
Well, there are nutrients that have a really narrow window, where you're going to
teeter between being deficient and toxic. And I think a really good example of this is methylfolate.
So a lot of people and patients come in, they say, I have the MTFR gene, and I can't make
methylfolate. So I'm going to take a bunch of methylfolate. Okay, so this is what happens. So
sure, they may be deficient in it, and then they start to take their methylfolate, and they get in,
they have some positive effects, and they're like, wow, this stuff is really working. So I better take
more of it. I better keep on taking it. Well, really quickly, people can get into a toxic zone with that.
So other nutrients, my point of this slide is that some nutrients have a really tight window,
and they're going to be harder to, I wouldn't say harder, it's going to be more work on your part
to kind of get into that just right area. And I will say this is that we can also use labs.
So for instance, zinc, you know, if you know your deficient zinc, and you start taking it. Now,
zinc has more, has more of a bell curve like this, where you really have a lot of room to be in
that Goldilocks area. But we can, we can look on labs, but let's just say that with Kinesiology,
we think that you're deficient in zinc. So you start taking your zinc. And you can, you can be
able to stay under this area right here with, with, with a lot more than, let's say like methylfolate.
So this would be kind of zinc, and you're taking it. And that's a really wide range. And we make sure
that you're in that area. And with methylfolate, again, you just have to be careful. So again, if there's
any questions you can post, I'm like, well, what do you think of this nutrient-doctor holder,
is it more of, it has a tight window, a tight Goldilocks area, and you think it's, it's bigger. And
I can, I can guide you on that. So the last thing, which is really important when you're, when you're
supplementing, is to know what's actually absorbed into your body and what is really not absorbed into
your body. And so I like this list of absorption from easiest to hardest. So I talked about how I take
liposomal glutathione. So I literally take a couple drops of it. And it's, it's, it's really because
of the, the way it's absorbed into your body. So when I take, let's say I take a capsule of glutathione,
I can take a couple of those and get the effect about the same as just a couple drops of the
liposomal. So liposomals are, are powerful. It's basically, you're just encapsulating that particular
nutrient and kind of like a, you know, microscopic fat ball so that the delivery is better. So your
body's actually getting it. I also like liquids as well. Liquids, you can titrate up and down pretty
fast. powders are nice, other than they, they don't taste too good. Sometimes you have to mix them up.
But you do, you do have the ability to cut down and on the powder if you want to kind of try and
get in that glialoxone and then getting less absorption or in the body would be a chewable capsules
and tablets. So it's just a reminder that when we're, when we're going to be taking nutrients that
you may need a lot less if you're at the top and then going down with the absorption. So I hope
this was helpful to you. I know that it's been extremely helpful for me to get down this,
this sort of tool that helps me go home and be able to figure out what I need in terms of staying
in that Goldilocks area. And again, it's, it's something that where you can learn more about your body.
We are always testing to get into your Goldilocks area in the clinic. So,
merst assured that you are there. But again, there's other things that people like to take or
they've hear about. And so I encourage you to try and start using this tool. And again, if you have
any questions, post them below. That was nice talking with you and I will see you at the next webinar.
Thanks.